oh that we have divided in three our  kingdom  it is our fast intent to shake all cares  in business for my age conferring the  money on their strengths what can you  say to draw a third more opulent than  your sisters nothing my lord nothing  will come of nothing speak again where's  my daughter by day and night he wrongs  me every hour he flashes into one gross  crime all other that sets us all at odds  of not into it who is it that and tell  me who I am why not by the hand so how  am I offended should be ruled and lived  by some discretion that discerns your  state they like my daughter doesn't it  disease that's it night mess so I  brother  here I stand the slave a poor infirm we  can despise don't  [Music]  I am a man more sinned against than  sinning  better thou has not been born and not  off pleased me better  [Music]